what i'd like to do in this video is try
to figure out what x to the fourth
minus two x to the third
plus five x
divided by
x is equal to so pause this video and
see if you can have a go at that before
we work through this together
all right so if we're saying what is
this top expression divided by this
bottom expression another way to think
about it is what do i have to multiply
so i'm going to multiply something i'll
put that in parentheses if i multiply
that something times x i should get x to
the fourth minus 2x to the third plus 5x
now how do i approach that
well there's two ways that i could
tackle it one way is i could just
rewrite this expression as being and i
will just make this x in yellow so i can
keep track of it i could just rewrite
this as 1 over x
times times x to the 4th minus 2x to the
third
plus 5x and then i can distribute the 1
over x
and so what is that going to be equal to
what's going to be equal to
x to the fourth let me do this x to the
fourth
over x
minus
2x to the third
over
x
plus 5x
plus 5x
over
x
and so what are each of these going to
be equal to
x to the 4th divided by x if i have 4
x's that i'm multiplying together and
then i divide by x that's going to be
equivalent to x to the third power
so this right over here is equal to x to
the third you could also get there from
your exponent properties in the
denominator you have an x to the first
power and so you would subtract the
exponents you have the same base here so
that's x to the third
and then
this part right over here what would
that equal to
well it's going to be minus 2 x to the
third divided by x to the first well by
the same property that's going to be x
squared
and then last but not least if you take
five x's and then you divide by x you
are just going to be left with five
and you can verify that this indeed if i
were to multiply it by x i'm going to
get x to the fourth minus 2x to the
third plus 5x let me do that if i put x
to the third minus 2x squared plus 5
times x what i can do is distribute the
x x times x to the third is x to the
fourth x times negative 2x squared is
negative 2x to the third x times 5 is 5x
now i mentioned there's two ways that i
could do it another way that i could try
to tackle it is i could look at this
numerator and try to factor an x out i
would try to factor out whatever i see
in the denominator so if i do that
actually let me just rewrite the
numerator so i can rewrite
x to the fourth
as x times x to the third
and then i can rewrite the
minus 2x to the third as
let me write it this way as
plus
x times negative 2x squared
and then i could write
this 5 x as being equal to plus
x times 5 and then i'm going to divide
everything by x
divide everything by x i just rewrote
the numerator here but for each of those
terms i factored out an x and now i can
factor out x out of the whole thing
so
i sometimes think of factoring out an x
out of the whole thing is reverse
distributive property so if i factor out
this x out of every term what am i left
with i'm left with an x times
x to the third
minus
two x squared
plus five
i ended up doing that in the wrong in
the same color but hopefully you're
you're following plus five and then all
of that is divided by x and as long as x
does not equal zero x divided by x is
going to be equal to one and we're left
with what we had to begin with or the
answer that we had to begin with so
these are two different approaches
nothing super
super sophisticated here when you're
dividing by x you're just like hey
that's the same thing as multiplying
every term by 1 over x or you can factor
out an x out of the numerator and then
they cancel out